what is this in JavaScript it's a
keyword that references another value
usually an object that represents the
current execution context okay but what
the hell does execution context mean it
either refers to your global environment
like the browser or nodejs for when used
inside a function it references the
object calling that function at a given
time
open up the browser and run console like
this you get the window object back
because you're in the global execution
context doing the same thing and nodejs
from the command line gives you the
global object back things get
interesting when we talk about function
context define a function and then
console.log this inside the function
body now if we run this function in the
browser we'll still get the window
object back that's because our global
context is executing the function now
let's take that same function and use it
as a property on an object when we call
the function on this object it
references this object now sometimes you
might have a function and an object
defined separately you can tell the
function to use some other object as its
this value using the functions bind
method the result is a new function
where any references to this inside the
function will point to the object that
you pass as the argument here but where
you'll see this used most often is in
constructor functions using the new
keyword the new keyword allows you to
call a function that creates an object
where this is automatically bound to
that newly created object and that means
you can create properties and methods
like many other object-oriented
programming languages for example we can
define a property like this name then we
can define a method like say hello and
use this to reference the name property
on this object and that gives us a
convenient way to keep the data and
functionality of an object tightly
coupled together but there's a lot more
to this than meets the eye so keep
watching if you want to go beyond 100
seconds and learn some more advanced and
weird aspects of this but first make
sure to hit the like button and
subscribe
oh hey there thanks for sticking around
this is a special bonus segment where we
can slow things down and take a deeper
dive into JavaScript this which gives
you plenty of rope to hang yourself with
if you like this extra segment let me
know in the comments because there's
always room to go beyond 100 seconds
over the next few minutes we'll look at
some caveats of this look at the bind
call and apply methods and look at some
more practical examples of object
oriented and functional programming
patterns so when I'm writing JavaScript
code and I see this I always try to ask
myself what is this but unfortunately if
the answer is not very clear because
this in JavaScript works differently
than a lot of other languages and it
just seems completely weird if you're
brand new to programming
now here's caveat number one strict mode
and non strict mode back in the earlier
days of JavaScript there were certain
features of the language that sucked
and so with es5 they introduced strict
mode to turn some of those features off
for this video I'm going to assume that
you're in strict mode if you're doing
front-end development
you're probably in strict mode without
even realizing it but it's important to
note that this behaves slightly
different if you're not in strict mode
one of the most important differences is
that in strict mode if you call a
function in the global context this will
be undefined instead of referring to
window or global and node this usually
isn't a big deal because in most code
you'll just reference window or global
directly and not use this as a reference
to those objects now that's one thing to
keep in mind but I think the single most
important caveat to understand what this
is how it works with arrow functions as
you can see here we have an object on
the first object property we have a
function defined with the function
keyword it's the same example that I
showed you at the beginning of this
video this when called by the object
references the object that called that
function now if we write a second
property and use an arrow function
you'll notice this is now the global
object or undefined in strict mode in an
arrow function this is based on the
enclosing objects execution context
which in this example would be global in
other words it doesn't have its own
binding to this so it looks up to its
parent and closing object and uses that
this value if you've ever used a BAS
you'll notice in the documentation they
tell you to use a regular function
keyword as opposed to an arrow function
and that's because they're not really
suitable for methods because of the way
they interact with this so now that you
know some of the caveats we're going to
look at three prototype methods that
live on a function object bind call and
apply let's start by looking at bind
because
I think you'll come across this one most
often let's imagine we have a function
and an object and these things are
immutable meaning we can't change them
the function reference is this inside
the body which in this case would be the
global context but we wanted to use this
other object as this we can create a new
function that's bound to this object by
calling bind on the original function
and passing the object as the argument
when we execute this function you'll
notice that this now refers to the
object we passed in so bind gives you a
way to explicitly set this on a function
now in other cases you might want to
call a function with a different this
context but not create a whole brand-new
function and for that you can use call
or apply in this example we use the call
method on the function and the first
argument to it is it's this context that
you want to set this will call the
function immediately and you can pass
additional arguments to it as well for
the arguments that go to that function
and lastly I'll point out that you also
have the apply method which is identical
to call the only difference is that the
second argument is an array of arguments
a good way to remember the difference is
to thank a for array or apply or C for
comma or call call is more common in
modern JavaScript because you can use
the spread syntax on the arguments when
you're working with an array but the
bottom line is that they both serve the
same purpose to call a function with an
explicit this context now it's worth
noting that you tend to encounter this
much more often in classical
object-oriented programming
versus functional programming both of
which are programming paradigms that you
can use in JavaScript for example one of
the big motivations of react to use
functional components over class-based
components was so that developers
wouldn't have to use this in their code
because it gets even more complicated
when you have a big framework with a
bunch of dependencies and components
personally though I find this to be very
straightforward when working with
JavaScript constructor functions let's
imagine we wanted to create a horse
class when this function is called with
a new keyword it creates a new object so
we can create methods and properties on
those objects by making a reference to
this so this works much more like a
class definition in other languages like
Java Ruby Python and so on and
JavaScript actually provides syntactic
sugar for this whole process using the
class keyword but we'll save that one
for a future 100 second video because
there's one more important thing that
you should know about this and that's a
thing called method chaining you'll see
a lot of JavaScript libraries that allow
you to chain method
together like this always keeping a
reference to the original object so how
do you change methods together in
JavaScript well you simply return this
from your method and now you can chain
together an infinite number of method
calls thanks for sticking around to go
beyond 100 seconds I hope you learned
something and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]